TOR NOBYE: Hi, my name is Tor
Nobye, and I work on the Tools
Android team.
Today I want to show you
the brand new IDE
that we have for Android.
As you can see here, it
looks sort of dark.
That's a optional dark theme
that a lot of us like a lot.
And on the left here, you can
see the Project Explorer,
which shows you the files
in your project.
And then we have the Code
Editor in the center.
And the Code Editor is really
the star of this IDE.
It is a very, very intelligent
editor that can do really,
really fast refactoring, code
completion, and so forth.
And I want to show a few of
those Editor features in
detail today.
All right, so here we're looking
at some pretty typical
Android code.
But notice that we have some
hard coded strings here, or
what appear to be hard
coded strings.
Turns out they're
actually not.
This IDE can present these
strings as if they had been
hard coded.
So you can see here--
as I hover, I can
see the real code.
I can click on it and I can go
in and actually look at the
real string.
But the IDE gives me a much
simpler view of the code,
which makes it a lot
easier to read.
And we don't just do that for
strings-- if you look further
down here, you can see we are
manipulating some icons, and
over in the gutter on
the left you can see
the real icon itself.
And we also help you with
completion here.
So if I invoke code completion
or just do show doc with F1,
you can see we get this
completion dialogue which
shows me all the
assets as well.
And that works not just
for icons, but
for strings as well.
So if I, for example,
click on this one,
you can see we have--
actually we only have two
translations for that string.
And furthermore, this also
works on colors.
So if I jump to, for example,
the color file, you can see
that we see all the colors
previewed in the gutter.
Let's take a look at
the code again.
One of the really nice things
about this new IDE is that it
does really deep
code analysis.
So if I, for example, scroll
to the bottom here, you can
see that it has highlighted this
line and it's saying that
this is a potential null
pointer exception.
The reason it knows that is that
we have added adaptations
into the Android platform.
So we know which methods can
return null, which methods
can't, and in fact we also
know-- for example, which
constants are allowed
for which APIs.
So it is flagging this
[? cull ?] right up here to
set layout direction right.
Which looks good, but you can
see it's telling me that the
concept that we were expected
to pass in here is one of
these named constants.
And so we use this data not just
for code analysis, but
for code completion as well.
So for example, context
getSystemService, you now-- if
I invoke code completion, you
can see it's offering all the
valid strings, which
is something we
couldn't do in the past.
You can invoke actions using
the Show Action dialogue.
So I'm going to type Inspect
Code, and you can see Inspect
Code lets me run on the whole
project or individual files,
and this is how you basically
run code inspections.
And we've integrated Lint, so
you get all the Lint errors,
but you also get a lot of code
analysis that IntelliJ already
comes with.
And it's really great
at finding a lot of
bugs in your code.
Let's talk about layout.
So if I jump into a layout file,
like this one, you can
see that we now offer
you a preview on the
right of the layout.
And this preview stays in
sync with my edits.
So if I, for example, click
on this text right here--
and I change the text.
Let's see, what should
we change it to?
How about to reset?
You can see the preview
updates on the left.
And the key thing about this
preview is, you get to work
with the code, but it keeps
the rendering on
the right in sync.
And you can also click in the
editor or in the preview.
And it syncs the selection
between the two.
Let's go ahead and create
a new layout.
So I'm going to create
a new blank layout.
So when I'm typing new layout
tags, you can see that it
actually helps me complete
my layout on the right.
So the error panel is saying,
hey, you have this widget but
you're missing [? a size, ?]
so we can just click on the
link to make it do that.
If I make a typo, it detects
that and offers to fix it.
And this is basically done for
a lot of typical errors that
you might have as you're
editing your layouts.
Another feature we have is
multi-configuration editing.
So if I jump back to my
stopwatch layout here, I can
turn on the ability to see this
layout across a number of
different layouts.
When I do that, you can see we
actually get a preview here of
what the current layout that
I'm editing looks like.
Here we have it on a tablet,
a large tablet.
We have it all the way from a
3.7 inch phone up to a 4.7
inch Galaxy Nexus.
It's showing a Nexus 4 on the
top left, and we have a seven
inch tablet and a
10 inch tablet.
So this makes it easy, as I'm
editing, to see if I'm making
any mistakes.
And this isn't just
for screen sizes.
We have many other aspects.
So I can, for example, switch
to translations here.
I can see this layout across a
number of different languages
and so forth.
And again, as I'm editing, it
will generate previews of what
the edits look like.
So I can make sure that I, for
example, don't cause the text
to crop on these different
languages.
So that's layout preview.
We have this not just
for XML editing.
You obviously-- if you prefer,
you can do layout editing with
a full UI builder as well.
This is something we're
still working on.
But as you can see here we
have our UI builder, with
Property Sheet, Palette,
and so forth.
And Layout Preview should
work here as well.
And I can go ahead and make my
edits and as you can see the
previews will update.
And the reason that this one
didn't is because this is
using a different layout.
So we have a custom landscape
layout here.
That's used when you have
a large tablet.
So just one of the ways you can
make sure your app looks
good across all the way from
phones up to tablets, is to
use dedicated layouts.
And creating new layout in
this IDE is very easy.
We basically have this Create
Other item in the layout
editor, which takes the current
layout, creates a copy
of it, and then you can
customize that for the
specific form factor
you have in mind.
So there are a lot of
new features to
investigate in this IDE.
This is just a preview build,
but please give it a try and
let us know what you think.
Thanks for your time.